you probably have a bunch of subscribers
right I mean yeah but not a lot of them
watch the stuff that I
do it's one of those yeah I mean this
might get like a thousand views oh great
whatever so uh started oh we're
started let me check on the internet
let's pretend it has started and what do
you think would be an interesting way to
start out um
okay so I guess it did
start so um does it look good let me
see dude that looks amazing what do you
mean the quality is not oh I forgot to
change the settings that looks amazing
you think so yeah dude what are you
bitching
about looks nice I guess that looks
amazing dude you made it sound like
looks better that looks
amazing yeah yeah dude jeez
you really you really uh how what I mean
under promise under promise overd
delivered on that
one well I just play how I see it
sometimes yeah that's great oh is this
my volume yeah so I could turn it I feel
like I'm quieter than
you is that your mic volume though yeah
that's what I'm hoping and not just my
lack of
confidence can you keep talking we
should have uh mic check one two mic
check one two mic check one two I feel
like uh in the middle uh maybe right
there a little higher maybe just like a
deciel higher hey hey hey hey hey hey
yeah that seems good yeah hello hello
hello do I seem quieter than you um I
feel like we're even now yeah we're even
yeah this is nice equality equality this
is uh this is the only podcast where we
start out with a sound check
but this oh my God this is real and
authentic what what
happened people comenting Janice is
sending me comments that some people
wrote one of the nicer
ones ha oh I kill Tony yeah how'd it go
tonight cuz I walked in like when you
you walked in late yeah you were like
did you watch my set and you made it
sound like it was bad or something well
did something happen I missed it um well
Tony said I did uh a shorter amount of
time I don't think it was that short but
I did come in a little bit under and
made sure to point it out what was it
supposed to be a minute M I like that
minute thing man I do like it because
it's just like let's just go bang bang
bang you know what I mean it's like well
it depends on how people use it because
some people use that minute to like say
nothing and then have one punch line and
some people like hey how'd you like that
and then they rush through it too much
yeah yeah you still want to do comedy
that's but it's not the same it's a
different yeah at that show it's
definitely like a different format yeah
like the style like you definitely can't
be like doing a chunk
obviously yeah you can't be doing your
you know your tip five no yeah it's
interesting yeah it's like what is it
that I'm doing in five minutes that I
can't do in this amount of time it's
like makes you think like am I getting
away with [__] in five minutes I'm
just like you know what I mean this guy
knows what I mean right right and then
there's some bits it requires you to
like kind of like win them over for a
couple minutes yeah CU it it might be
like too dark or something yeah you know
do you have to do a new minute every
week on that show that's the thing okay
that's a pretty sweet
gig yeah you you have to so you have to
do they do it every week yeah so that's
50 what 56 minutes you got to do a year
two minutes 50 there's 52 weeks 52 weeks
okay okay I don't know why I thought
there
was I'm like out Asing you right
yeah dude how about tonight we're
hanging out this in the hug ones we're
hanging out at these parties and it's
just like us talking everyone's like oh
look you you oh my God you guys are just
hanging out because you look the same
yeah and it's like you know two black
Comics talk two white Comics talk
everyone's like oh no one says anything
no one bats and I yeah cuz they're like
they have to talk the blacks they have
to like convene and like figure out
exits yeah yeah Asians just like oh my
God you're like with another autistic
person you guys can communicate with
each other look at you being so cute are
Asian people autistic yeah really are
you autistic yes okay I mean you're not
you're you don't think I am on the
cooler edge of koreanness I will say
when we talked on the phone earlier I
was was like oh he does not want to be
on this phone right really I can sound a
little Curt and tur I was like I was
like all right I'll
go I was with a friend and I felt bad
cuz he was oh CU you were talking well
okay because I just want you know some
there's some stuff where I'm like ah I
just we'll just get this over on phone
call you know yeah instead of being like
oh my bad are you coming I'm I come in
or you yeah you know what I mean yeah so
um okay so that's what it was
yeah do you like phone calls uh yeah I
do you do right yeah it cuts out a lot
of [__] I feel like a lot of comics
like Fone they either hate it or love it
yeah it's too intimate for some it is
right because you feel like you can't
escape yeah you know you know who calls
me who William
Montgomery I didn't meet him but I saw
him on on the stage he seems like really
cool guy yeah he get he gets a big you
guys are like Superstar
dude like when you guys get introduced
like the regulars yeah like they go nuts
dude some of them do that sometimes dude
like I'm sure you get a big pop like I
saw Williams well you know really varies
oh
really you know perception or whatever I
just assumed everyone gets a big butt
yeah I mean that's [__] cool dude
that's a really cool show too Kil Tony I
never really I just see like Clips
online I never watched like the full you
know yeah but watching it live like dude
that's so funny because kill Tony is
already such a fast-paced show and then
they only get the clips it's like even
more yeah clippy you're clipping already
something that's made to be clippable
right right it's like yeah it's like
yeah so you uh got a good sense of it
you think yeah it seems like a [__]
rock and roll show dude it's that's a
fun time dude I
mean that I think that's a really cool
idea idea too you know yeah so are you
really
autistic I mean like you've been
diagnosed or is it just like uh that
people say it I just feel like I don't
always try to be cool or like I don't
think social situations are like the
most important thing going on at any
given moment mhm I'm like doing
something else in my head yeah you get
social
anxiety yeah like like sometimes I get
that like I'll be like [__] I'm do I
look like an idiot right now like I'm
not talking to anyone you know what I
mean like at Mi earlier like I feel like
if I didn't know
anybody and like nobody knew I was a
comic I'd be freaking the [__] out like
in my head I'd be like [__] I look like
a like imposter syndrome yeah I'd be
like I feel like the biggest tool bag
right now you know like I was going to
say the f- word but we're live on
YouTube I don't want to get you taken
down [__] no uh maggot why would
you what how would do you feel like a
[__] can you say that you might get
take I don't want to get your Channel
stri or whatever no yeah they always I
don't care you know what annoys me is
when people censor swear words on the
Internet it's like this is what Janet
Jackson fought for and you're just gonna
[__] yourself like that do you ever get
flagged um yeah um no not really oh no
really that's uh yeah so you feel like
auti but you but you but you probably
like being autistic yeah Define autistic
what do you mean by that just not always
in social situations
always 100% trying to okay be present
and you know like you're saving yourself
a little bit for some other [__]
that's going on you're like living for
something in your head yeah so like
daydreaming yeah like a serious case of
daydreaming all the time now be honest
with me are there times where you're
like kind of [__] up and you know
you're kind of being not the most polite
maybe in a social situation and you just
go I'm autistic yeah yeah and then you
go that works yeah all right I [__]
knew you guys do that bro that's all of
it knew it yeah that's what we're doing
when're doing that like when you [__] up
with someone you're like I'm autis and
then do you feel like most of the time
people go oh
okay like they give you yeah they're
like oh he's not communicating properly
so I have to take whatever he says as
like
just you making sure it's look it's good
yeah let me
see yeah that's what we're doing that's
like five seconds
behind dude that looks great dude does
it maybe it looks worse this looks
amazing dude before the podcast where
the listeners at home he was like yeah
it looks like [__] the video it was a
little better I'm looking at this it
looks like [__] Oppenheimer dude holy
[__] looks like Christopher Nolan
directed it maybe for some of the other
streams it was worse yeah it's
um yeah that's uh that's great um what's
that just something just popped up the
chat do you see that in the middle oh I
don't know if that says like seems
important there is not sufficient space
to continue recording okay so we'll just
stream it we don't have to record it and
that's the same recording on the video
okay because it's the same thing yeah
okay so that was that was good I pointed
that out right no no okay it wasn't that
important but it was it was good that
you did okay that just for just I don't
know for yourself or
I I just wanted to make sure it wasn't
you know yeah like not not recording
yeah now I know that it's not on the
computer it's just recording on the
YouTube I upload all my videos to
YouTube I just said it's to unlisted and
I have like all my sets oh I do that too
yeah it's like a storage it's a giant
storage for me how many years back does
that
go like nine holy [__] but not
everything I didn't I wasn't recording a
lot until recently like video yeah I
record try to record all my hour sets or
my headlining sets I don't always do an
hour I never do an hour how's
your uh headline set looking on the road
it's fun I'm getting better at it it's
hard right like the first like it's like
God damn cuz every place is so different
too yeah
and the buildings are different and
stuff but like I have it so nice with
the kill Tony crowd cuz they're the best
crowds I'm so lucky dude I bet you could
just yeah yeah they're just happy to see
me some of the time yeah absolutely yeah
and you could just get away with murder
I mean you could say anything like yeah
you know what I mean like they're not
going to be PC yeah it's hard for me to
do PC rooms now I wish I could don't
have that muscle anymore like a Brooklyn
room or some [__] yeah yeah cuz I'm just
saying [__] and stuff yeah that's more
fun yeah you know Texas audiences you've
felt them yeah it's so much easier I
guess it is yeah just cuz they are down
they're less PC and [__] yeah like you
can't be PC here if you're PC I mean you
can still take it too far if you like
just turn into like a straight like Fox
News thing yeah just being offensive for
the sake of being offensive kind of
thing yeah for sure then they're like
okay we get it man but for the most
part it's like yeah and it's always
easier to make fun of liberals than it
is conservatives because conservatives
you're just being mean you're saying
they're stupid and dumb and poor but
liberals you're saying like oh you're
making a choice to act in a way that's
unnatural and weird looking right so
it's always just easier to make fun of
and then they're not as invested in
their ideas like rednecks if you make
fun of their ideas then it's yeah more
personal yeah with liberals their ideas
are like so goofy yeah like cappuccino
and yeah Steve Jobs yeah that is true
that is a little like I never known a
stat they don't have a
God yeah most of them are like atheist
or some [__] right or they're like just
about like medit whm Hof breathing or
some [__] yeah like there's really no
like yeah that's true and conservative
conservatives are obviously like super
religious are you religious no I used to
be I grew up in the Presbyterian Church
he's liberal guys he's liberal I'm a
liberal I'm a communist so you grew up
Presbyterian Church yeah okay I grew up
like Roman Catholic holy [__] yeah
that's intense like uh Korean Jesus and
everything Korean Jesus from 21 Jump
Street yeah oh remember that that shit's
so funny yeah you got a rosary yeah
apparently you're not supposed to wear
it around your neck but where are you
supposed to wear it on your you're
supposed to just keep you're supposed to
just keep it in your pocket oh [__] yeah
but I don't you just have random beads
in your pocket all the time oh there's a
cat it's fine um yeah I just uh but if I
keep it in my pocket I just know I'm
going to lose it so I'd rather just keep
it around my neck yeah you [__] pull
it out with your phone and just gets
caught yeah yeah exactly yeah that's um
trying to get some girls
number yeah yeah that's oh let me just
throw this away
yeah I gotta say man Texas is really fun
you guys got it really good down here
right we have backyards yeah we have
garbage day I guess every day is garbage
day every day is garbage day yeah where
do you live in New York I live in uh
Queens we're in Queens for Queens for
for till I don't know what that is is
that like 71st St yeah that's exactly
71st da I know Subway I'm play dumb dude
I don't know where I know your game now
dude he under promises and overd
delivers that's his game the video
sucks I just know he it's his Game Stops
it's his game that is a good game
because you're GNA impress people every
time you're gonna win every time it's
not really good for comedy in comedy you
kind of want to put it on the surface
what you have so funny tonight hans's
like I don't want to say the guy's name
but he was like walks over to us and he
goes oh look at this clout chasing
[__] oh
Ari Ari
Maddie I say because it's not
true he post some weird ass [__] he's
Estonian he posts Estonian [__] which I
get like most of your followers are
Estonian but yeah where is I don't know
I don't even know it makes me mad that
he wants I refuse to find out where it
is he's such a big personality I just
want to take away some of his power yeah
I met him in
Brooklyn and he remembered me and I
remembered him and uh there was a couple
people that like yesterday when I was at
the mothership like they were like oh I
met you and I was in my head I was like
thank God I'm like nice to people cuz
like most of your interactions were good
they were all like you know but thank
God I'm like a nice person yeah I
remember you yeah you're the guy that
shoved me right right you know but like
you know we all know Comics that are
like just dicks to people for no reason
H and it's like I'm like d damn like
that that shit's going to catch up to
you bro you're going to go to another
city and they're going to be you know
what I mean yeah you're going to be like
oh I remember you you were the dude that
was a [__] dick to me at the but
isn't it so easy to be a dick to
comedians because they're so sensitive
and it's like oh yeah I don't what's
your name again they're like how did
dare you yeah they hate you forever do
you feel like you're sensitive yeah yeah
yeah yeah me too I'm like I'm not here
to make friends I don't need to be good
at this oh you're like that sometimes I
don't it's one of these like I didn't do
I didn't start comedy to make friends
one of those that's my worst impulse I'm
I'm acknowledging it so I can work on it
and get better do you go to therapy look
at his guest spot look at his [__]
camera hog she just can't stand that
we're not paying attention to is this
your cat no it's Brian's oh Brian is
Brian your only uh room I have one other
okay roomy this is a sweet Place dude
you guys got it good down here yeah it's
pretty affordable too oh really
yeah interesting yeah we'll talk off
here about that I I don't want to
embarrass my room I don't care if people
know I want the IRS you know stupid
cat just so perfectly in shot and frame
and whatever this would be a great clip
clip that she's uh I did a podcast with
sugar Shan Al in here and she was uh oh
really showing off her butthole in that
one that's cool that's going to be a
good uh that's our producer that's her
that's her thumbnail yeah yeah that's
actually a pretty good
thumbnail yeah that's um so did you grow
up like super Korean and oh not that on
the hey hey she's going on the keyboard
now
that's that could get that could get
real dicey oh now she's going to the
soundboard this lady this lady really
knows how to pick it she really knows
where to iing put her paws at they love
that keyboard oh my God oh God Brian's
to me that cat rules he says D don't be
he can hear us yeah [__] yeah
dude he's always texting me like audio
video problems and stuff like oh he mic
is
yeah yeah that's cool man did you grow
up like super Korean cuz yeah yeah
pretty much were you like the only Asian
dude in your high
school yeah I guess so yeah yeah me too
yeah in uh Belleview Christian oh you
went to a Christian High School yeah
Christian Middle and Christian
Elementary it's just they have the whole
thing retically integrated are you close
to your
parents not right now but it was when I
had to live with them oh really when I
was a child and I relied upon them do
they know like how well you're doing and
[__] yeah or they they don't acknowledge
it what don't acknowledge it like they
acknowledge it yeah yeah I mean they're
not like texting me all the time about
it but they're like
oh yeah they're like
surpris yeah yeah oh do you speak Korean
yeah oh really okay yeah same here yeah
oh nice yeah I grew up and all my
friends would speak English to their
parents but I me and my family we spoke
Korean and I think that's why we learned
how to speak we kept it longer than they
did yeah I see I see yeah my now me and
my family it's like a for me at least
it's like a mix Korean English yeah you
know but you still like use Chen you
speak respectfully when you're speaking
English do you feel like that no no it's
like totally like casual like I I'll be
like I'll talk down I'll talk down and
I'll be like what are you what are you
doing you just shamed them like I've
totally like flipped it yeah you you
scold them or I'll just be like like my
dad he's like very lazy so like he had
like a heart issue recently and like
it's cold where they live Northeast so
he's like I don't go outside cuz it's so
cold out I can't go and I in front of
like everyone I was just like you don't
even go outside when it's warm out what
are you talking about you caught him in
a little mind shortcut that he had yeah
so was that what something fell
something fell yeah some dust did I
bring my fanny pack in here do you smoke
weed
uh not on camera I just uh I'm on
probation oh right so you don't smoke
okay no smoke we my New Year's goal for
2024 is to be sober oh the entire month
or yeah I'm 30 days in right now okay if
you want to smoke though feel free I'm
not like no I don't want to do it then
no I don't I really don't
care I uh I don't know where my fanny
pack is but no yeah you got you were on
probation or no I was kidding probation
yeah but um yeah so I totally like I
flipped the dynamic between me and my
parents cuz you know with Korean House
so it's supposed to be very like you
yeah so you just broke the fourth wall
get down you're just a normal person now
you're not constricted by tradition they
used to verbally they did dude I was
abused so much verbally you know ker
they freaked the [__] out yeah did your
parents like yell at you like
aggressively yeah they just fall into
pits of Despair exact
yes that's what I mean yeah and then
they would just like dramatic the wicked
I saw yeah ex exactly yeah just like I
think that you know where I think that
[__] comes from is like
krama they exaggerate it yeah cuz KD
drama you ever watched K drama yeah it's
just all emotional that's what I mean
just [__] ringing your eyes out every
scene it's like who is living like this
yeah that's what I mean this is exactly
a conflicted Society you shouldn't be
communicating so you know dramatically
yeah it should be like everything is so
life death but dude have you like uh
heard the stories of like the [__] that
they went through who the not our
parents generation but the generation
before that like my grandma the Korean
War and [__] yeah my grandma speaks
Japanese oh because yeah so embarrassing
just she's like watching Japanese shows
and stuff is like aren't you kind of
glad that Japan Japan occupied you
because now you're watching Japanese
[__] now like you can't hate them that
much right right right right right
that's true it's like how much can you
really hate someone that you're a fan of
yeah that educated
yeah yeah proper tongue I think that's
where that [__] comes from though but
our our culture is like killing it
though I was reading this book about it
and I was like I guess I didn't realize
how much our culture is like killing it
like yeah the movies yeah squid game
[__] I mean that's like the biggest show
it's like our black panther it's a squid
yeah is that our black panther I mean
put us on the map we got the par
parasite parasite junho um
K-pop yes k-pop's like the biggest music
ever like records wise BPS gets like
everyone on the base level yeah a Gangam
Style that was such a good song yeah a
good vibe and then
um Karine barbecue oh yeah kbbq Pugi
yeah you like progi yeah best made ever
I like sun sun I love
this La I'm not a huge fan of I think
it's too tough there's like little knot
that you get sometimes oh yeah that is
true but when it's good it's good when
you get that
sweet texture yeah but then sometimes
you get like just like a knot and you
have to like chew around the through it
yeah yeah yeah I like that you don't
like that just get through it some of
that [__] is good I guess yeah you like
tooth workout yeah it's a little little
grimy yeah kimchi chig that's good yeah
does your mom make good Korean food yeah
I used to eat this thing every day for
breakfast called tbab yeah yeah EG yeah
of yeah of course yeah it's like really
soft yeah it was like a Peeping pup but
it's just my special like egg and go
Jang a shitload of cheese what are you
kidding me sauce can't have it without
go J yeah
is actually what I actually like eating
everything else is just an excuse to eat
go Jang and Sam Jang right it's like
yeah
yeah [__] [__] Spoonful and just
mix it I will say rice is probably the
worst thing you can eat in the morning
it is not good for you that's why all
Koreans are emaciated because we're
eating like empty calories all day yeah
but it's good to have a society of a
billion people or like live in tiny cuz
rice is like reliable yeah that is true
I don't eat anything in the beginning of
the day like I fast me too you don't you
feel so much better yeah I feel like I'm
emptying out my stomach like yeah just
clearing it out getting rid of all the
junk and then filling it back up dude
like I don't understand people that eat
like a big breakfast I'm like dude how
are you getting anything done that's
crazy yeah I feel like Joe Rogan was the
one that influenced all people to stop
eating breakfast really
yeah I heard it from someone I just
heard um about fasting from someone else
intermittent fasting yeah yeah yeah I
was like oh it's a good thing to not
just have constantly food in my stomach
all the time it's good to clear out the
furnace and clean it out and then put
stuff in it I guess he does have a big
influence on people though Rogan yeah I
guess he does subtle ways too and in big
ways
yeah no
what is that non when you hang out with
cool Korean people you don't look at
your
phone that's what Brian texted me in
Korean yeah he can hear us
yeah Brian why oh he's saying I'm cool
so don't look at your phone yeah ah [__]
so I don't or maybe it's prescriptive
like don't look at it or it's like
saying hey this is something I noticed
about it's observational maybe yeah yeah
that's
um that's great yeah this is a is that a
casket hray yeah pry Co Tony made by
bonesy or his brother I don't know his
brother gave it to me yeah that's pretty
cool dude [__] it yeah you guys got it
good down here you got you wearing a
Rolex I noticed that earlier I was like
he's got [__] Rolex Mariner whatever
Daytona whatever that is Daytona right
Daytona Daytona is a part maybe it is I
don't know much about Rolex I watched a
bunch of videos when I first got it was
a gift from the grandpy himself yeah the
uh what is the St Ries yeah calls him
okay that's nice a Rolex I just started
getting into to watch this I was like oh
I noticed everyone at mits is out a
[__] Rolex I was like where the they
just handing these out
at yeah Tony had one you had one I was
like there a couple other people had one
I was like it was the same one too yeah
the the Submariner that's what it's
called This Is The Joe Rogan what the
Austin Rolex that's how you know that's
how you know you're in when you got that
I'm gonna get a fake one and just
[__] I'm gonna get a Let Let Me In
look at this no that's great dude
[__] do you feel do you feel it like
the I used to when I I first put it on I
was it was Heavy I was like like wow
official yeah yeah now I never take it
off I we to sleep no you don't yeah
really why I just don't want to have it
out and someone take it oh you're like
paranoid I guess who's goingon to take
it Brian
also probably got eight of them I don't
notice it on my wrist now I mean I've
had it on for so long but I have a tan
Mark it's winter
but I uh yeah I'd never take it off I
probably shouldn't wear it as much like
Jamie uh told me that he doesn't wear
his
Rolex because yeah cuz someone might
steal it yeah and I'm like I'm way
poorer than j i yeah I have a nice uh
cardier and I was wearing it one time
and um at a bodega like 400 a.m. in New
York and this guy was like cardier
Santos and I just covered it up and I
was like no it's
fake yeah trying to be nice I was like
it's just out of his 4:00 a.m. and he
was a he was a certain you can't be nice
at certain times of the day well yeah I
mean come on 4:00 a.m. and it was he
looked a little sketchy like a little
thuggish and I was like um you know yeah
you just checked his Vibes but how did
he know that what your watch was it
instant like instantly watch guys just
no like I I like I knew that was a Rolex
you know but aren't there like a lot
that look like sometimes like I try to
catch it I'm like oh no this is like
every watch is pretending to like you
know a bunch of watches like pretend to
be the band yeah like the Omega they
kind of look Ro Lexy yeah and the uh do
do do other people like ever point it
out to you the Rolex yeah are they like
Rolex sometimes not very often but
that's the thing is like that's I know
you didn't like but that's the whole
reason I believe that people buy Rolex
is so that some people might be like
Rolex and you go
ah you know you know it can't be a
grumpy Rolex where
shut up right right right right they're
doing it for the world you can't have an
attitude about it you're like dude you
can't be like sh it's like when a girl
wears yoga pants and then is like
glaring at you for staring at her ass
right it's like you know what you're
doing it's like why it's on your wrist
are a [__] that's funny I I did point
out a Rolex that uh someone was wearing
one time it was a girl and I was like oh
that's the presidential Rolex that's
nice and she covers she goes damn I'd be
trying to hide my [__] [__] and
I was like well you weren't sounds like
she stole it from her
accent no just kidding that's but you
know crazy ACC but you know what I mean
no it's like you're not trying to hide
it you're wearing it yeah you want it to
be noticed yeah you want it to be
noticed why are you getting weird feel
like you're not want it to be noticed
yeah it's like don't do that cover up
the slow the slow yeah yeah that's a the
watchman's shame you know what else
people get big about is like um shoes
cuz I just I got these Jordans like for
Christmas yeah and I'm not a shoe guy I
don't know but you look like a shoe guy
I'm really not I don't give a [__] about
sneakers I don't give a [__] about like
like but if you said you did I'd believe
you a lot of people would they' be like
oh this guy probably yeah is you know
you could make fun of someone for their
shoes and they'd be like oh they'd be
like roasted they' be like oh you got me
yeah yeah no I know what you mean yeah
but I I just don't I don't know I have a
buddy who like literally has like
hundreds of pairs of shoes like I don't
I don't relate to that it's like but i'
I've been wearing these and like so many
you realize how many people are like
dumb sneakerheads are like oh is that
the Jordan 5s 2B you know High Top
midtop low footage I'm like I don't know
they like doing that they like looking
at you like yeah good J props bro and
also them knowing it is like a prideful
thing yeah right that's what it to
compliment you by bragging about how
smart they are that is true that is what
it is huh so it's like a
compliment cluster bomb that just goes
in every direction it's like they're
just jerking off on you with their big
dick yeah and you just have to sit there
and let them do
it yeah yeah are you a sneaker guy what
do you are no I'm wearing a Mir that I
bought from
bonesy I don't know
air I see I don't
know see that just show which I don't
know yeah it's the STS the St of Myers I
just think it's so weird to like know so
much about something that's just on your
feet yeah it's like you know what I mean
it could be like the least important
thing yeah you're choosing to make it Mo
most important that's what I mean it's
on the ground all day yeah you know and
like people are like you know was he
texting about
sneakers
who he text you in
Korean um yeah now he he he's never done
this
before oh we're both yeah he didn't know
that if he thought he was going through
like a Korean fetish thing and like
getting Korean yeah that's what it was I
didn't know this is cu I was and I text
back like oh
he's so he's just using Google
translator like crazy yeah where I think
his girlfriend is helping him it's his
girlfriend Korean yeah oh my met her
Janice oh at the at M M oh okay they're
dating that's Brian's girl yeah they're
feeling Saed up oh [__] I didn't she's
Korean yeah ah why didn't you tell
me uh I guess it'd be weird if you told
me I don't know yeah I didn't know talk
about after that there was no exit
strategy with it is weird that I was oh
okay it's weird cuz I I feel comfortable
with you but like I I I hate talking
about like Asian stuff with like
non-asian people yeah I'm Asian but yeah
because they just ask you like so what's
that like and you're like I
don't you know I get like they're
tourists or like they're trying to mine
you for Content or something yeah like I
get like annoyed like they're like so
what's it like being Asian in comedy I'm
like I don't I don't know I get like
annoyed I'm like I don't know how to
answer suspicious of their motives right
you know what I mean what are you really
asking me you really I mean what is that
the bre thing yeah there's no way that's
that works I know it's just basically a
container for water tap water for tap
water yeah why don't you get the Alex
Jones big uh there's like a real good
one it's like a couple hundred dollars
Alex Jones sells it he I think he like
SP it's like a sponsor or something but
it's supposed to be like really good
it's like the supposed to be the best
filter oh [__] yeah I don't have it but
yeah I mean I'm not really you know I
grew up with the brda I'm just like I
need something that holds
water really you don't care about like
water quality no no okay I should be
though don't get the Alex Jones
filter sounds
intense Alex Jones what do you think
about Alex
Jones I um I don't know much of his
stuff to I mean I've watched a couple
podcasts about I mean he's very
entertaining yeah you know obviously the
frogs are gay stuff um I get all my
stuff from Clips like I don't I know a
little bit about stuff so you're like
online a lot in clip form yeah like clip
like I didn't I never really watched
long form like people talk about stuff
and I'm like oh yeah I saw the clip yeah
you got a vague sense of the world
that's why even today with kill Tony I
was like wow that's a cool like full a
long
clip where are the captions
I can't understand a [__] without
captions they don't censor the swear
words in this one or the balls spoiler
alert don't spoil anything by the way
why is this longer than six seconds this
is weird I don't
like yeah I know this The Vape Cloud
yeah it's um was that Brian texting you
again yeah it's great it's like a it's
like a hidden
guest they a
how do you how what's it like living
with the comics it's fine they're cool
yeah we're all like cats do you guys all
stay up late I feel like what you know
what in this situation I guarantee you
one person doesn't really stay up late
but like two of you guys do no we all
stay up you guys all stay up we all have
similar cuz we're working at similar
hours yeah that's true we're all working
pretty hard we're all pretty successful
yeah so cuz you there's like even if you
like um in the same like success what
usually there's like one person that
just ends up being like an early bird
but I guess not with this one yeah you
know what I mean though like yeah one
person it's just like all right dud I
was on a I was on a trip yeah and it was
with this other Korean guy and he always
had to be the first one up that's what
I'm saying he could not there always
that one the one sleeping in that's what
I'm saying yeah there's always a one
that wakes up early and he's like M you
smell the breakfast as you're like kind
of like half asleep you know yeah he's
he gets off on that though that's like
his thing it's like I I'm awake like he
looks down on you guys yeah like I have
this for the rest of the day now I hate
people like that I [__] hate people
like that it's annoying because then you
feel like compelled to play this game
with him and you get less sleep yeah
that's not don't don't play that's not
true you don't get less sleep like I saw
then the thing is he'd always be falling
asleep that's what I'm saying like
you're tired as [__] and you're just
wake up early cuz you're so anxious
about the social situation that's
exactly what I'm saying you're just like
ruining your sleep yeah it's such a
Korean thing to think is like just you
know taking sacrificing things in one
area is going to help in another but
that it's not necessarily the case just
because you're in pain doesn't mean
you're gaining he's being a real
goog he's a nice guy he's a good guy he
was just I mean he was like 17 okay
doesn't know any better yeah kids are so
insecure ah dude I was so insecure
they'll find any reason to [__] find
pride in themselves I hate those people
that wake up early like I saw this
speaking of Clips I saw a clip of Steve
Harvey being like
[__] wait I wake up at 5:00 a.m. [__]
Wall Street been open since 5 so I wake
up when Wall Street open oh no so what
what's your ass doing cuz by waking up
when [__] something that opens when
you're waking up when Popeyes is opening
right exactly that's a little racial I
didn't mean to yeah that was of all
things Jesus Christ Millions open late
you chose the one waking up you're
waking up when six street is waking up
yeah it's like and then he's like and
you wake up at 8 and Wall Street been
open 3
hours your ass and I'm like people
always do the thing like I wake up early
I'm up while you're sleeping and I'm
like yeah well guess what when you go to
early you're sleeping and I'm up yeah so
are you bragging about you're getting
less sleep you're scientifically it's
proven now everyone wants to get more
sleep yeah what's this game of you're
sleeping and I'm up haha I win it's like
I have a more inconvenient sleep
schedule than you it's harder for me to
adhere to my sleep schedule than yours
right cuz I chose this weird schedule SL
hours I I just hate when people do that
game of like oh you're lazy CU you wake
up no I'm not I just got a bunch of [__]
done from midnight to 5:00 a.m. [__] you
I'm not lazy you should shame people for
the hours they work not when they choose
to work those hours it's like arbitrary
what what do you care a prostitute is
working at 2 a.m. right doesn't mean
they're not working hard I hate that
[__] [__] anyways like I you know we
work really hard to
like I don't know I just hated when I
went to like high school and like you
had to set an
alarm and you have to be up wor you know
what I mean for children for adolescen
yeah like I'm sure you never wake up to
an alarm never unless it's an early
flight yeah same like yeah that's the
goal like why would you your beautiful
organic body to conform to Wall Street
this be myth belching Smoke Filled this
[__] man-made [__] yeah like a
machine it's just going to CH you but
eventually only human yeah it's like I
don't like I don't know it's
[__] what's the best way to treat a
zoo animal you want to be like come on
bear it's 6:00 a.m. it's time for you to
wake up and stretch like a
Madagascar yeah right that's not my
Canon I was watching that movie on the
plane um but you're relating everything
to Madagascar now yeah but like you know
when people like I don't know like
there's people that are like oh you're
going to tell your little joke I'm like
yeah want have fun uh s your alarm
tonight huh about that what you know
what I mean does this actually happen no
but I'm just making like just in case
just make it up [__] who's shaming
each other for their Lifestyles I think
we're pretty open-minded just tense
situations in my head and just make it
up yeah you think you're so much better
than me Mr office man yeah hey one of us
in this room has a s alarm tomorrow and
it's not me all right I'm waking up when
the night terrors take me yeah yeah it's
um I don't know what time do you wake up
like 12 yeah dude 1 [__] Rockstar
life
dude wouldn't you would you have it any
other
way I would maybe be a little more on
the ball with waking up yeah and do you
want to wake up earlier I just don't
want to lay around for two hours you do
do that checking things yeah I'm like
I'm working do you work out I try to now
you seem fit you you look I'm muscular
strong I need to do it's like residual
memory from my 20s when I used to work
out like a beast beast you see like you
have biceps and [__] thank you man yeah
I'm really insecure about the size of my
arms I don't think I have very dude my
arms are like a tenth of the size of
yours are you [__] kidding me but I
feel like Asians don't have big arms I
have big legs I don't have big legs
either I have thick legs
mud the leg of a radish we should just
capture
time you say a Korean word and you know
they have the ball bounce
Moon learning
Korean Hans Kim and Andre Kim it is cool
we have the same last name like I said
people would always tell me about you
cuz we had the same last name I know I
saw you at the mother ship and I was
like okay either he's going to be a
friend or like my mortal enemy it's so
funny that's that's what I thought about
you before I I was like I was like
coming to the Mother Ship I was like I
was like I was like uh I know Hans is in
Austin and I was like he's either gonna
[__] hate me or he's gonna be like
the coolest dude he's either gonna be
like they go room for one Kim what the
[__] are you doing I was like or he's
gonna be like hey brother the more the
marry so when I when I saw you and
you're were like bro [__] good [__]
like what are you doing I was like oh
thank God could have gone really bad
dude could have been a problem I was
like I got no friends out here dude I
got no bad back up you know yeah well I
mean so many people come through there
that are like so amazing and it's just
you just fit in with those people I'm
like oh yeah these are one of the
amazing people that come through here so
I was just like yeah no that was really
nice of you I was like shocked I was
like
okay I was like I know this is just
racist but do you want to be on my show
like just cuz you're Korean like follow
me on Instagram and like messaged me and
followed up I was like this guy is like
really nice holy [__] dude yeah just
keep telling people that no it was like
really nice like it was my first time in
like my first night in Austin you like
yo come do this come do my podcast let's
get you on this and that I was like holy
[__] dude like this guy he's like come
hang out come hang out with me in my
place I was like
okay [__] so nice dude it was it's
awesome thank you you know yeah I mean I
guess I could be nicer to people in the
scene oh you just do that for me yeah I
just asse do that to everybody I uh you
know don't do that huh to everybody well
I try to I just I get exhausted I feel
like I'm exhausted a lot yeah tired yeah
do you feel like you're nice to people
you seem nice I saw you interacting I am
nice to people called one guy Cloud
chasing [__] but other that was just
boring I just trying to
stimulate myself you feel like you're
nice to
iconics yeah I mean I try not to get in
their way if I'm not going to be nice to
them but MH I think Comics are the best
I think that they are the
closest to a family or a cult that we'll
ever have mhm and uh you know it kind of
scares me how like how like I'm so
vulnerable and open to them like you
know like yeah very similar lives and
stuff but could you be nice to a comic
that you don't find funny at all like on
stage yeah you're not like one of those
like like you know some people all pitch
I like get the [__] out yeah like you
you have to have that you can't just be
friends with someone you think is
awful but I I don't think like I know
it's tough it is
tough you're thinking about something in
particular right now well I'm just
saying it's just tough because then
you're you know they try to give you a
tag and you're like
yeah
M what's Brian saying Hans had that La
rooftop Korean Vibe of the I did a show
like a month ago that just came out now
everyone's talking about it what show
kill Tony oh the one in New Year's Eve
oh where was that HB arena in uh holy sh
Park wow really yeah arena show yeah
Jesus it's a lot of
Clips
yeah those clips are doing well dude
they're going to be out there soon holy
[__]
dude I am not
aware that's great you guys are you guys
are like [__] rock stars out here I
mean it's all Tony Man Tony built this
thing on the strength of his skills it's
all you know and he developed it over
the years and now it's like the biggest
thing ever he just kept doing it kept
putting it up and wow that is true he
seems like a really nice cool cool guy I
met him for the first time yeah people
think he's going to be a dick but he's
why do they think that just cuz his
personality on stage he's like a roast
comic he's like oh stop those people are
usually like the sweetest people yeah
that's what I'm saying it's like it's
usually the clean comics the people
Comics are like strictly clean that are
like [__] dicks to be honest with you
that's why you want to hang out with
dirty Comics cuz at least you know yeah
what they're going through yeah like
[__] I it's it's like the opposite
when you're hiding it when you're hiding
your battles it's like yeah what are you
fighting you're like overcome
compensating for something yeah right
yeah yeah do you go to therapy no no you
ever think about it I've been thinking
about
it um yeah I mean I just find it weird
it feel feels like you're introducing
money into the whole
brain thing of what therapy yeah oh like
like you're paying someone and they're
obligated it's like not genuine yeah
yeah yeah yeah
you can say about anything though you go
to a restaurant you pay for it but it's
like not genuine yeah I just want food
but if it's like my head yeah that's
true I don't want like
industrial Scaffolding in there
industrial
scaffolding that's you read a lot I used
to yeah that you that's something that
someone that reads A Lot says I used to
read a lot exactly yeah now I just like
pick words out of like a thesaurus yeah
you're not like you're not like me where
I'm like yeah that sounds
cool that's like my biggest BR word yeah
that's crazy
dog industrial scaffolding if I use that
in a sense I'd be so pumped are you
kidding me dude sounds like a band would
you used to read like um fiction 48 Laws
of Power oh you read that yeah what do
you think about that you ever psychopath
plan yeah I think it's a good way to
look at the world occasionally I think
it's good to have that gear but I don't
think it's good to live there I I tried
applying that [__] sometimes and I'm
like I I have to stop I had to stop I'm
like dude I feel like a [__]
sociopath yeah like is this a coet who's
you know yeah demonstrating higher value
or keep your friends close but your
enemies closer I'm like do I have to
Jesus go shake his hand it's good for
your career yeah yeah yeah [__]
what's what's what's your favorite uh
law from the 40 Laws of Power like like
you feel like like you're not doing what
you're doing and don't appear like
you're doing what you're doing like
always just lying to people and throwing
them off
descent my thing is Robert like who are
you
battling you know what I mean like
you're you're an
authoring your depression like who are
you competing with in the in the
literary world with all these [__]
you know what I mean why is your yeah
why is your [__] so strong man like how
is it just to talk to this guy is he
always like trying one up you or
something like yeah who who's your enem
crush your enemy absolutely like who are
you the publisher like who the [__] are
you but I think it's a good thing CU
that is what's going on and it's good to
just be like hey this is what is
underneath all this conversation and
[__] is like struggle for power at
the end of it but I don't think it's
good to live there I think the flourish
on top of that is more beautiful and
more worthwhile than like you know just
thinking about like oh is this power am
I power now that' be exhausting like
that dude you know it's like ego [__]
you know do you feel like do you feel
like you get a big ego sometimes like
like yeah yeah it's easy right to get
there especially if you're like
sensitive and stuff like yeah when the
world doesn't make sense to me so I'm
like oh
then I'm then you you think like a
dictator like oh they're all wrong yeah
you ever get grossed at when you look
back on certain things and you're like
oh God such all ego that was gross
youever do that you're like [__] that
was gross of Me no never
okay he's in dictator mode foreign
concept to me it's a heretical thought
I'm kind of yeah look at this hey mie
I'm a little allergic to cat I'm going
to Li mey is
this yeah how long have you had uh this
is Brian's cat right yeah I've been here
two years look at her [__] that's
what it is weird you can see her [__]
that's what the other guy said too shaan
shaan was he in the butthole yeah he I'm
a bigf fan yeah he's the real deal who's
your favorite fighter shaan obviously
you just saying that come on no you had
honestly he's most people's favorite
fighter right now he's so excited he's
pretty popular yeah yeah um who else is
out there I'm I'm so behind I'm more
like fight are you 2019 you know who I
uh recently just became uh friends with
is
mazol he was in the crowd at the the
Miami Improv oh my God he's a comedy fan
yeah uh not really I mean he kind I mean
he's not like he saw you through the
clips the clips go both ways I actually
saw him do the Clips the Ben Asar
knockout yeah that fight was a clip that
was a clip that's a good thing when
you're fight it's either a good thing or
a bad thing no but I was like such a big
fan of his and he was in the crowd and I
was like nervous to perform and then it
like it went well and then he came in
The Green Room map and he's like bro I
[__] love you dude and I was like oh
dude thank God yeah you know and then we
went to like because he's like the king
of
Miami I was opening for uh Piven so like
we all just went out he like MZ all just
showed us
like like the real Miami yeah Miami is a
town of access dude like she wants to
play with your pen like there was there
was a line around the block at these
clubs and we were just with h and we
would just walk right in yeah and it was
just like I was like this is so crazy
dude like and then at 6:00 a.m. we went
to some like strep club and he handed me
$500 in
singles keep me mind I Was Made 400 for
the weekend and he handed me $500
singles you just pocketed it made it
rain on
yourself stuff it in my pocket so and I
was like what's this for and he goes yo
you made me laugh tonight dude have fun
and I was like yeah he's like yeah man
you made me laugh tonight yo have fun
and I was like all right so he calls the
girl over he's like yo yo grind on her
and I was like and he was like harder
and I was like what the [__] he's he's
like he grabs my hand he goes yo smack
that ass dude smack that ass oh and I
was
like I was like uh she loves that
keyboard
maybe it's the light
too
Lily Lily you just ruin my [__] mol
story thanks for
that why is your would you just pull
your dick out
earlier can't sit in these pants oh it's
like too tight
yeah I I gained so much weight I'm
heavier than I've ever been how much do
you weigh
1776 [__] I weigh like
152 I weigh 160 and I lost a bunch of
weight fasting fasting just unnecessary
weight that's good you don't want to
carry around weight you're going to die
sooner yeah that's what I tell people
you never see a [__] jacked old guy
90y old yeah they're all thin they all
look like us thank you
Asian we're here for a long time not a
good
time or both oh yeah yeah you just
reversed us I see what you did there
yeah made it more sad yeah that's um
look at her she's liing herself and [__]
so you're a 2019 UFC guy you've been any
fights yeah when I was uh opening up for
Rogan in the Arenas we would do an arena
like Friday and then go to the fights
Saturday [__] dude was that like I
saw Leon Edwards knock out Usman Usman
yeah no way you were there in [__] uh
Salt Lake City I guess so I forget where
it was in Salt Lake City but yeah
because of the altitude oh okay remember
because um that was a big thing about
that fight huh that's right I was at
home watching um didn't affect my
comedy I actually watched that fight
with Mike carrian in The Green Room in
Brooklyn oh [__] yeah mutual friend my
what Green Room uh this place called Old
Man hustle uh Brooklyn Club OMH oh used
to do the little one yeah Ed knows you
yeah Ed and I way back dude he talks
about he [__] loves you cuz him and
Mike are good friends yeah and he he was
always like he's like [__] no Hans he
booked me when nobody else that's what
he was saying yeah yeah that's what he
was saying yeah he got the first cut at
this juicy Peach that's what he was
saying he loves you
dude yeah yeah he was always like know
Hans dude he's like he's like dude trust
me I knew Hans was funny before
anyone well I hope hope to prove him
right you know you should go stop by his
Club when you're love to I did once oh
you did in it was cool people it was
cool right yeah Brooklyn Comedy Club
Williamsburg New York go check it out
it's such a beautiful Club it's the best
like Club I think you can fit so many it
feels like a club that's in the middle
of the country right you could have like
Headliners there that is true yeah it
kind of has like a maybe like the riot
in Houston kind of yeah maybe maybe
maybe mean that's not
yeah what the [__] was that that was a
cat a cat oh my God sound like a little
child I was like what ghost is [__]
haunting this place dude children are
creepy man what um are you on the road
this weekend yeah I'm going to bavia
Illinois do you like flying no do you
get scared when it gets a little
turbulency no no I just don't like how
it makes me nauseous you get nauseous on
plans yeah like you're
have a No usually not but it it can what
airline what airline do you go with
whatever is the
cheapest this my guy you save more money
in the long run I think do you log your
miles yeah I have a thing for each
Airline and I'm like well let's see who
wins it's just a slot machine every time
yeah let's see yeah you do you um you so
you get nauseous every time no I don't I
try not to but I know it can if I focus
on it mhm it's just hard cuz you're
there's no ground you're used to ground
you know yeah it's not natural yeah
you're up in the air and like I don't
know when it gets a little turbulency
like I'll like I'll be like oh [__] like
I'll grab onto the tray and people next
to me look at me like I'm a [__]
like this [__] guy and I'm like [__]
you dude don't act like I'm a
[__] like you know this is not you know
what I mean you know you're scared too
don't act like yeah you know but the
thing is that if you grab the tray and
that doesn't help steady you then your
brain is just like working overdrive
like what the [__] is going on so I just
try not to even
notice yeah do you get I just try to
like just shut off complet I try to
sleep I sleep mostly I I used to um do
you try to like coma toast yourself with
weed edibles no you never do that I used
to but I got so like when I get high on
Edibles like can't breathe
properly it makes me more sick you're
one of those it makes me nauseous that
gets me such a bad
headache are you serious yeah I don't
want to like traveling is stressful I
don't want to like you get stressed out
traveling yeah it's stressful on the
body you're getting radiation radiation
yeah in the air it's like an x-ray or
something no that's not true yeah you're
getting radiated is there science behind
that yes there's no science behind that
how much
radiation on a
flight about 035 micro seevers I think
is you're exposed to lowlevel
radiations why is that because flying it
it does like Tire you out and that
always fascinated me because you're
really just sitting there you're not
moving yeah but at the end of it you're
like tired like yeah you're just like
little bounce around like you're
basically in a little you know those
science tubes where they like just shake
it around very slightly
yeah right just getting moved around and
I heard it's because like the air is
real thin when we're up there so that's
why we get tired too yeah I mean so I
don't know what's going on really you I
don't know why we get tired you know the
rad you know where else do you get
radiation charging your phone really
apparently that's like a lot of r
radiation I think also the pressure you
know when you land and you take off
uhhuh that's like what does planes in is
the pressure difference it doesn't
matter how long you've been flying it
only matters how many takeoff and
landings you do for how when the screws
and rivets are going to come off a plane
that is true because when you take off
your
ear yeah that [__] [__] me up oh really
oh you're like really sensitive to that
we all
are that's why you get tired that's why
you get tired on a plane you just don't
know what's happening you're like oh I'm
tired I wonder what that is anyways you
get tired a lot yeah I have a chronic
neck injury oh God he's got a thing for
everything I get tired of a name for
everything I have a neck injury you have
a neck injury yeah so you get tired from
that yeah it's like slowly sapping away
my
energy what are you talking chronic
injury have you ever had a chronic
injury but how it's in your energy over
because you're like like a thing in your
finger you know what are you the
Energizer buddy dude your batter's
running out in your [__] in your back
or some [__] it is what happened to your
neck how'd it get injured jitu just
people cranking on it yeah yeah that'll
do it yeah next are weak were you good
at yeah next are very weak I didn't do
it long enough to get very good but I
had fun doing it and I had my moments
but you know I did it for a little bit
yeah it was very fun
I mean
yeah yeah it's a it's the uh ultimate
sport youever have to use
it not really no yeah sometimes yeah
sometimes so yeah yeah I mean I never
had to like put someone in a triangle
choke or anything but you never had to
use it like in the street or anything I
guess just to maintain position and
balance in certain
situations what during sex or some [__]
yeah I that
too what you're trying to say no I
you're trying to be like classic I don't
know like when you're like you know it's
falling over or something it helps me
fall better oh I see I see that's I'm
sure there was a moment when I was like
yeah on top of someone like a like you
know I fell on on an escalator or
something yeah but yeah I had to punch a
guy in New York really recently no when
I was living in a vanent like 2019 yeah
that's how I know Hans by the way like
I'd be at the grizzly pair in New York
and people would be like are you related
to Hans and I'd be like no they be like
oh he lives in his car be like oh cool I
had a thing I had a catch I had a hook
that was literally how people knew he
lives in his van down by the river and
now there's other Comics that live in
their van you like Inspire first you
like inspired I was like you can be poor
here too yeah he like inspired this like
two couple two tree Comics that like
live in people are scared of New York
and living in a van in New York
especially but it's actually not that
bad people in New York are professionals
at minding their own business yeah New
York's why people are really scared of
New York that blows my mind I was scared
of a scary place I was scared walking
down the strip over there there [__]
cops with machine guns you know what I
mean that's scary that's safety that is
safety but yeah that's how I knew Hans
people would always be like he losing
his
van and you guys have same last name
yeah I guess that's a big deal to people
I mean it's just like people have like a
lot of you know like meaning behind like
the fact that oh I'm Society approves of
me I have a decent living thing and they
just be like I don't need that [__]
Society they're like you're going off
grid right right cuz it's scary to them
so like you stick out like at least I
have this nice apartment even though I
have to work eight hours 10 hours a week
a day if anything they're slaves to the
system they're they're the Sheep they're
hostages the Sheep you're the wolf if
anything yeah you know free I'm the
sheep that went over the fence
and you're the sheep that took off the
grass right next to the fence you're a
you took off your clothing and you're a
wolf you know what I mean I mean would
people people maybe I'm just like a Ram
or like a like a goat would people uh
ever tell you about me in those days I'm
sure they would have okay that's enough
you just say
no I mean you're way more successful
than me that's not true at all dude
they're like uh do you know Andre he he
l in a [__]
apartment he's doing this weird thing
where he has decent living standards I
love how you think you're most
successful me you got a Rolex on that's
I mean back when I was living in a van
in New
York I was like no
nobody who mean who's successful like in
the early days of New York though you
know what I mean you so you spent eight
years there nine I'm nine well actually
yeah that's crazy I'm in my ninth year
of Comedy I've only done three in New
York yeah yeah I never really went to
any other city like I obviously for like
like one nighters or something you know
what I mean or like well yeah I mean New
York is an awesome City that's where I
cut my teeth it's a great City to cut
your teeth at you know which is great
cuz everyone in New York like everyone
respects that yeah that's true you go to
another city you can't be like Oh I'm
from Cleveland no one you outrank him
that's
true I will say yeah now that I've been
here and I say I'm from New York I see
people kind of be like oh huh right it's
funny people like really measure you
they're like where do you get up at in
New York and I'm like the stand and
they're like
oh and I'm like oh you were like
measuring me right there what was that
I'm just answering a qu you know what I
mean yeah I think uh Americans they tend
to do that without like you know they
think that they act like they're so
innocent it's like how can this be an
innocent question like you have to know
that this sort of like you're like
sizing me up they they don't they don't
have any Shame about that they just like
I just want to know I just want to know
how successful you are why are you being
worried about it right you know what I'm
talking about right yeah I think Asians
are more subtle about it but they still
do it do it to a more gross degree
sometimes yeah I don't like feeling like
I I was just sized up it makes me feel
like I'm I was just violated like you
just went through my wallet you just
want to Vibe with someone that's what's
good about comedy you you can see
someone's comedy and be like Oh I like
that guy and Just Vibe with him you
don't have to be like oh where did he go
to school where did he learn his CL
right like juliad like musicians or like
whatever it's so funny cuz like you ever
have it you're in like a new environment
and like no no one's ever seen you
perform and they're kind of like when
you try to chime in they're like okay
who is this guy chiming in here yeah and
then they watch you on stage do your
thing and then afterwards they like ah
dude what's up yeah how are you and
you're like I didn't know you're were a
hot girl
yeah that moment is always so funny to
me but I wouldn't have it any other way
yeah I wouldn't want them to just give
it to me yeah that's true I guess I
guess you do have to earn it yeah yeah
and it's like I don't want them to
respect my looks or anything that is
true but isn't there a part of you
that's like Dude I was cool before I
[__] went on you know what I mean
always cool well yeah I guess if you
feel like you're always cool I always
feel like a dirty loser is just taking
up space and stinking up the place do
you yeah Jesus and I go on stage I do my
job and then you're [__] funny though
dude I was watching you too last night
oh thank you man [__] great jokes
like just bang bang bang bang like just
one after the other just you know what I
mean Mohammad Ali thing you remember
that yeah okay I did that one today oh
really at the uh at the kill Tony it did
well last I mean I didn't see on kill
Tony but like I remember that because
Muhammad Ali is like my favorite figure
yeah so that was he refused to go kill
Asians do you get like when you go on
stage like on the creu show or something
like that do you get like a big pop like
people are like yeah that's him
sometimes yeah that's pretty cool
yeah that must be pretty cool it's the
best yeah I'm like I don't deserve this
[__] now I got to go on you really think
like that well yeah you can't be like
yeah I deserve that well you don't think
you deserve it but you just I always
have in the back of my mind like oh
remember the hate cards I like remember
the negativity just so that I don't hate
comments you read hate comments not all
the time do you get a lot of hate
comments no okay yeah I do do you really
sometimes yeah well you know that's
actually a really good thing yeah it
means I'm they care about you I'm in the
public eye you you ever hear that Vince
McMahon would say to his wrestlers back
in the day what because I don't know I
get a lot of hate comments too I so I
always tell myself this I swear to God
um believe that I uh he would say um
tell his wrestlers like in the back like
before the show started he'd be like Hey
listen when you make that walk out to
the ring and they're cheering you and
your music's going he's like that's
great
when you make that walk out to the ring
and they're booing you it's
great now when you make that walk out to
the ring and it's dead
silent now we got a
problem yeah and that always sto with me
but I mean that's wrestling you don't
really want to get booed when you go up
as a standup comedian I know all right
you don't have
to he's that guy he [__] dissect the
analogy no I'm just trying to find a way
to be miserable I guess but yeah no like
I don't I love that that they actually
love you they love you think about it
how many times do you ever comment on a
YouTube video yeah how many times in
your life probably like twice in twice
six months in six months yeah
so eight so eight times in two years
yeah so these people are doing it all
day every day do you know how much do
you know how emotionally connected and
how much you have to care about someone
that's the worst way to type out and hit
enter interact with the world is
comments and then you're checking them
and you're responding and then you're
just you don't respond no no I'm just
talking about like in general I was
going to say don't do that Jesus yeah
it's not like the real world it's like
the Nether world it's like you're just
you're just looking because they're
commenting under a video the video is
the main thing that's what they're also
just piling on like there's one guy that
just wrote a hateful comment and they're
like oh I'll just say what he said you
know what I mean because they can't
think for themselves yeah they like that
and then they some people are good at
that like scientologists they like they
need a cult and then they can build a
framework upon that
yeah but yeah no I love the little boy
pop that's that's like it's like all I
need I don't I don't need anything else
I just want to yeah just have like a a
little bump up when I go up on stage
just to make those sets a little easier
well you've earned it well you know what
I mean I have been doing it 10 years but
yeah you've earned it it's not like
you're a [__] half half a year comic
that just [__] you know what I mean yeah
it's like you should enjoy the fruits of
your labor you know it's like I mean
there's some perks for sure yeah that's
amazing like the comments though you
don't really read them do you not
anymore used to drive you crazy I mean
yeah I mean for sure they they can you
know what you know I heard David got
Goin would do is like he would like read
in a voice memo like the comments hate
comments and he would just put it on a
loop and put it in his headphone and go
on a
run that's psychotic yeah because it's
playing outside your head yeah and it's
your own voice that's insane yeah that's
embedding that [__] into those words
into your head but it would like make
him run harder he would say how hard do
you have to
run
like is a bear chasing
you yeah you ever meet him yeah is he
cool in Las Vegas yeah he bet he's cool
he seems like a really cool guy as [__]
I read I read some of his book it was so
[__] dope yeah I forgot what it was
called but it was that's what you need
what is that gear you know like in
critical situations that you want that
guy in charge you don't want to yeah not
be able to tap into that mindset were
you popular in high school not really I
was kind of like a wild card I was sort
of like in a league of my own really
yeah that's the nicest thing were you
getting [__] up a lot in high school
not on drugs like drinking though no
really yeah I wanted to it just wasn't
accessible to me really so you were like
sober in high school yeah I was a child
yeah what about in college were you
getting [__] up in college a little
bit Yeah I get high like after after
school dude I would get so high cuz I
was like so new to it and just with my
friends just like it was like doing
mushrooms now or like assd yeah it was
like that so fun yeah we got higher like
back then yeah you know what I mean it
was like a different high back then
right when you first started yeah it was
like a trip yeah it really was were you
okay so I pictured I don't know I don't
know why I pictured you like I went to a
Christian School that's true but some
was Christian School they they like lash
out you know what I mean yeah so you
were in a league of your own in high
school yeah I was sort of like the weird
guy not really athletic yeah were you
friends with a lot of
people no I had like a couple close
friends couple and I was like I was
friendly with everyone else oh okay but
yeah it was
um yeah I was just like the people
respected me because I was smart like
cuz I got good grades yeah but that went
away in college
yeah you were really smart you seem like
a really smart guy I I mean I like to
think I'm smart but I don't think I was
good at school like to like a CRA like I
I know like kids that are good at school
I wasn't like at their level uhhuh I
just yeah I mean College was tough on me
I got like a 2.7 2.6 GPA really yeah I
didn't go to
college wow really yeah how did your
parents feel about that dude I mean
there were like some intense frying oh
yeah yeah dude I dude I was a bad kid
dude I was was getting arrested you were
a bad kid I was getting arrested in high
school like this is why you shouldn't be
good-looking you think I'm good
looking
no I feel like so that means you think
you're good-looking we look the same I
don't think I'm good-looking I don't
think I'm good-looking I think you have
a normal shaped head which helps I guess
all right let's not talk about my looks
well no I think like you had access to
cool people cuz you look good and people
want to hang out with people that look
good so you can have access to doing bad
things like I even if I wanted to do bad
things no one wanted to hang out with me
so I wasn't like I don't want to say I
was like like I was just like just super
skinny and like I don't know I was just
with the wrong crowd I was getting
arrested in high school selling drugs
getting into the fights skipping
school like just getting high in doing
the worst things like dude I your
parents must have been freaking the [__]
out dude I stole my parents car this is
exactly what every Korean parent is
afraid of like a nightmare dude yeah
other parents would tell other parents
about me they'd be like don't let your
kid hang out he's a bad
kid he's too American I went to summer
school all the time that probably made
it worse dude I used to prank my
teachers I bring an electric pen and be
like I need a pen don't have a pen I
give them an electric pen she the [__] I
get suspended for that and
[__] for the old pen trick yeah do you
remember the electric pen [__] yeah the
little buzzer yeah yeah made your thumb
feel weird yeah which it wasn't even
electric pen it was just like an intense
vibration it was an intense vibrating
thing well do they use batteries and
electricity yeah but it it was just to
make the vibrating yeah your thumbs like
yeah yeah yeah I don't know that's how
it worked yeah so like you have to like
like take it apart and rebuild
it for punishment well yeah I think
that's sad that uh you know kids that
don't conform to the system are just
so so mistreated and they really are we
want that we want creativity we don't
want everyone to be able to sit in a
room for eight hours a day yeah I
remember I went to uh I didn't go to
college and like whenever my friends
would come back like they they would
just all like talk down to me yeah I
mean their kids that's the only thing
like if they don't have that they're
nothing yeah it was just like a weird
time Liv no life right and that's that
that's what they're told yeah is like
the thing to do they [__] made it
they went to college you don't even have
to have a job after that as long as you
can go to college yeah did you graduate
yeah and then what did you like what did
you I worked at an internship for six
months and got fired for arguing with
one of my bosses that got hired after me
I can't picture you arguing with anyone
dude why you just seem like this
laid-back nice guy I can't picture you I
don't know what you think I
am well I don't know I mean in school
I'd like argue with the teachers and
stuff really I can't picture that dude
you see like it's just a laid-back like
happy go-lucky guy yeah because I'm not
in school yeah I guess so the thing that
got me a school is like the [__]
like the work like you're you're wasting
my time this is not you're not doing
anything for me this isn't for me you're
just bored yeah yeah yeah I could yeah I
could when's the last time you got into
an argument with a teacher or in
general huh I don't know you get mad e
yeah I have a temper but you have a
temper yeah it's been really good though
since I started comedy and oh that's
good yeah I think that's what it is it's
just like I don't know what I'm doing
with my life or whatever oh okay
but uh yeah I have a temper for sure
when's the last time you like got mad
like even just a little bit where you're
like [__] this
[__]
um can we talk about something
else okay it got too real it got too
real dude I didn't know we'd go I just
don't want to yeah yeah yeah yeah you
don't want to you don't you don't want
to say
give voice or give fire to the yeah yeah
okay all right I didn't know it get dark
Jesus all right we made a r I was just
[__] I thought maybe you'd say you
know at Starbucks they got your order
wrong or something uh last time I got
mad I remember I got mad at a comedy
club
once cuz I was like the the BART the
waiter came up to me and she was like
what do you want I was like uh I'll just
get something later after my set and
she's like okay come with me and she
just walked off and I was like oh my God
I don't want to deal with this right now
and then she she was looking at me like
a little too quick I was like I think
she saw me roll my eyes and I felt so
bad CU why did she say come with me cuz
she was like tell me your order come
over here I'll I'll show you what you
want this you want that oh I see and you
were about to go on yeah I was like
going up in like five or seven or four
minutes or something ah that was like
nothing yeah I guess I got kind of
annoyed um last time I got mad I got mad
at my friend Paul today cuz I was like
uh check a right it's like a kind of
weird turn there's like a bike lane here
and so you have to go over here but then
he missed it so I was like okay turn
right here because there's like another
little opening here and he missed that I
was like okay turn turn right here where
the road is and he missed that too he
just not going to turn I hate that yeah
it's like at least I hate that at least
respond on verbally don't you cuz it
frustrating but you know it's his car I
don't want him to make any right turns
that he's not comfortable making was he
giving you a ride or something yeah he
was doing me a favor oh dude I I hate I
hate giving people a
ride yeah cuz like I they just people
are the worst at giving directions yeah
like they'll be you know cuz they're
talking they're behind you they'll be
like turn right there right as you're
passing the street yeah and they're like
turning they're like oh that was the
right and you're like you didn't say
anything what the [__] dude yeah I've
been there though because it's like oh
he's going to turn right cuz you you're
used to this path and you're used to
turn right here so for you it's obvious
yeah and you think that's and then he's
he he doesn't know so you're like well
why don't you turn right like usually
yeah you didn't say yeah cuz you got to
say it before like driving driving is so
[__] up I hate driving you don't have
a car out here I have a van oh yeah yeah
yeah from the shop but yeah I think
driving is the worst what what's wrong
with it I think it makes people in a bad
mood I think it makes people aggressive
and hate each other and threatened and
only thinking about themselves you get
road rage yeah you definitely get road
rage I get a lot of road rage
this got this angry side I Korean people
do get do have a temper dude yeah I know
people have a temper it's CU like when
someone cuts you in line for the food
rations after the Japanese Occupation
you're like no you all right all right
so you're saying it's in our DNA it's
our [__] inherited trauma bro do you
think I have anger issues do I seem like
definitely you got arrested in you're a
child no wasn't unless you were like
collaborating with the
Japanese Hoots with the Jabs
dude no I think uh yeah I think we all
get angry sometimes you know I think
it's a survival thing I think somewhere
in our DNA was helpful to like get mad
yeah like if you couldn't like if you're
trying to spear like a fish and it keeps
getting away like [__] I'm [__]
hungry get it together yeah and then
you're out there for 30 more minutes
just [__] angrily just yeah exactly
and you finally get you're like okay
well I didn't learn a lesson there right
I got it when I was angry and in a bad
mood hopefully I don't have to do that
every time I want to catch a fish but
I'm glad I caught a fish you you know
what's the worst is when like you get
angry at something and like maybe you
like you're in an getting into an
argument with someone on the phone or
what and then you got to go on stage
literally a minute after that and you
got to go and you go hey what's up keep
it going for
the bit yeah better on my stuff though
hey you ever notice dogs drinking water
look like little
[__] was the worst moment of comedy
dude cuz like we're real we're regular
people too like we go through [__] life
[__] that's when I just try to channel
my inner Mark Maron be like yeah what
are you going to
do oh God you ever go on stage it's just
like miserable and you just don't hide
it with my you know sometimes with the
people I'm that I'm dating it's just
like they're on the phone like what are
you doing why didn't you call me oh
people do
that like with people that I'm dating
yeah they say that to you like why
didn't you call me yeah what do you
mean why would they say that cuz they
were in a call they miss me
oh I guess they're like suspicious too
they're suspicious they're jealous I
guess because you're a [__] you know
they know you're ack popping comedian in
you know what I mean and the women are
everywhere they know right they got to
know that they yeah they they always do
that thing to girls they're always like
say you I get girls after
shows yeah right they always say that
yeah like you can can get a guy at any
bar ever right exactly you're mad that
the odds are even now you have to rely
on me it's actually not even they still
have an advantage well girls they don't
really I feel like they can't open
themselves up like guys can like guys
like yeah oh [__] yeah but like okay
Watcher Andress and they're like all
being like
[__] girl scouty about it your
impression of guys just the regular guy
is
oh like to us it's like a j everything
is like a jackass prank MH it's like
we're just trying to do the craziest
thing possible and for them they're in a
murder
documentary don't you feel like women
are just such a big distraction for
comedy like kind of like does not help
me I don't know being in a relationship
and yeah it's like I don't know me I'll
be there soon honey okay bye yeah
that's You Are My One True Love and I
will never leave you wait yeah no that's
do you feel like that how old are you by
the way I'm 34
34 why [__] how there you 26 thought we
were the same age here how there you
wait so you were born in ' 89 yes
when's your birthday May 31st how old
are you I'm
uh 20 20 three no
Jesus 27 no I'm 29 okay yeah we're
pretty much the same
age not according to the [__] tax tax
the IRS only half a decade younger than
we're in a different age group buddy
what are you aen gen Z Zoomer we're in a
different age group according to the US
I'm a millennial I'm
94 yeah so both Millennials what's your
sign not to sound like a [__] broad
I'm a snake the only sign that matters
Gemini no yeah is that Gemini yeah I
usually don't know that but I got that
yeah people usually guess the one after
that but it's like in the bracket before
that do you believe in that stuff no
well I don't you answered that before I
finish my [__] question why do you I
kind of do the people born in the same
all act the same you know what's crazy
like I was born in the month of August I
have never ever met someone born in the
month of August that I did not get along
with well what if you also get along
with a lot of people but
yeah it was like a golden retriever
being
like golden retriever being like wow I
get along with these golden retrievers
like well you every was my friend in
this world yeah W you're like well
you're just really nice so what's the uh
thoughts
on the whole thing everything going on
what just uh Israel
Palestine
Ukraine I don't read about that Stu
Yemen do you gamble no really in Vegas I
will what' you play 21 blackjack yeah we
just lost $1,000 last week playing
Blackjack online in real life that
happens I lost like a hundred
bucks yeah I don't I don't like games
that I don't let's play hand right now
want to play hand right now play handed
21 yeah okay oh you got a 10 oh I got a
10 19 oh you're the dealer I stay I
obviously 17 you win it's basically
flipping a coin it basic
yeah okay let's all right how much do
you want to put on this let's go all in
this is how you get me you give me a
little taste yeah how much you want to
put on this Magical Mystery I don't want
to put anything on this oh come on you
can put something on it I don't think
that's what makes a good night is like
Risk okay I would rather all have reward
why don't we risk not having any risk
okay and just try to get all reward just
all just you know Sonic Hedgehog golden
coins Three
Happiness 12 hit against a three yeah
yeah oh
busted oh you would have lost anyways
yeah that's what I was counting on you
don't do sports betting like you never
bet on the fights or anything no I'm not
good I I at this point I would only
choose Fighters that I know like oh I
know that guy I don't know that guy Al's
fighting Cheeto yeah I'm watch that are
you gonna go am I gonna go no it's tough
because Saturday is like our money maker
night too like yeah is that this
Saturday when I'm in bavia Illinois
February 2nd or 3rd February 3rd I love
that yeah no it's not I think it's in
like oh it's it's going to be in Miami H
yeah UFC
299 you know what day I think it's like
early March early March holy [__] or
maybe like late February let me look
that up no
idea when that's going to be would you
go to that Shan ell friend of the
podcast would you go to that yeah yeah I
think he's the main event yeah he's the
main March 9th yeah obviously he's a
title fight March 9th
yeah
Miami I am in Sid Splitters Tampa you're
right there yeah Tampa Tampa's like
halfway up the [__] you're five hours
away you're not halfway up in the Gulf
Coast of the [__] you're not going to
make it there yeah um
yeah well uh this was fun I
um like I see you nodding
off you you seem pretty tired right I
was just excited about Tampa oh okay I
don't know I didn't seem that tired okay
I saw you wiping your eyes I was like
all right he's gonna that was a long
time ago okay I just had an eye issue I
always just try to end things before
people end it that's my let's see how
long we did we did an hour and 38 oh
that flew by it could have done longer
if it wasn't 3:00 a.m. I know there was
this was cuz he was like hesitating
doing the
podcast yeah he was like thought I'd be
too sad I wasn't going to say that but
he was like I'm a little tired I was
gonna say tired why lie I'm an open book
I'm a little [__] you're not an open
book yes I
am like you're like I don't want to talk
about what I'm
saying oh yeah remember
yeah so it's not really an open bu well
that's that's just cuz other people are
involved that's cuz um you're in your
period yeah you know I'll talk about as
long as it doesn't hurt anyone else like
I'm not that's the thing I'll talk about
anything yeah um but yeah thanks for
having me dude it's for doing it really
nice of you to uh yeah we'll probably do
it again tomorrow okay okay when's your
flight I I changed my flight to Thursday
why don't you get a place here yeah yeah
just get to a hotel
here um or you can't really
Airbnb no I I will next time I just got
to plan it out I just think that drive
is brutal I don't know why you're so
comfortable doing that drive yeah it's a
two and a half hour drive I'll get home
at 6 I would rather kill myself I I you
know I don't care it's I I don't
complain it just seems inefficient to me
but yeah I think that your mentality is
probably
better if I were in Houston I'd be like
Austin from Miami to [__] Seattle
what are you talking about that was like
a road trip yeah that's
true um but yeah if I was in Houston I'd
be like that's awes that's another city
I'm not that's you don't like Houston I
can't go there why not no I just mean
like if I was you I I probably wouldn't
travel to
Austin just because to me it'd be like I
can't it's another thing it's another
city I'm not there it's like to going to
Miami every night oh yeah but I guess
it's only 2 hours and people in Texas
drive all the time yeah it's two hours
you put on what do you think about
trains would it be great if we had a
train there that left every hour 30
minutes yeah I was thinking about that
there's no train system in Texas yeah I
mean communism unless it's like There
Will Be Blood or some [__] and yeah only
if you're coal yeah or oil wasn't that
film in like Texas or something or it
took place in Texas I have no idea okay
well um follow me on Instagram andreth
comedian very funny comedian whoever is
listening thank
you